alors juste que ce que vous allez dire
au premier ministre bachand embêté mais
peut-être ça comme il est ancien
ministre de l'intérieur peut être
proposé mes services peut-être pour des
cours de cette défense à l'elysée aussi
par contre et garde du corps si vous
faites ça vous êtes mon idole
on appelle tout de suite mais le vice
ministre la peine je vous jure que c'est
son vrai portable c'est son numéro il
peut décrocher un peu décroché trois ça
serait énorme égard va avoir des
problèmes par des problèmes et c'est
vraiment alors allo monsieur premier
ministre oui c'est c'est matthieu
delormeau monsieur le premier ministre
je suis dans une émission de télévision
avec mon ami cyril hanouna alors déjà
merci d'avoir décroché
ouais alors comme ça vous pensez que
donc le premier ministe cyril hanouna en
fait je vous explique
c'est que matthieu delormeau vous adore
et il rêverait de déjeuner avec vous
donc on s'est dit on va vous appeler le
nom
ce soit
rambaud aurait alors monsieur monsieur
le premier ministre est ce que vous
accepteriez des jeunes avec matthieu
delormeau de bad qui est tout individu
passeur sur le premier but est ce que
vous voyez qui je suis est ce que vous
voyez qui je suis
non mais man ray vraiment rochette mois
la luna donc lui propose ce soit lui qui
m'invitent d'abord à rabat m
mais monsieur le premier ça fait plaisir
j'amènerai matthieu delormeau c'est lui
qui paiera d'accord avec ça le premier
ministre
c'est énorme
non mais et les ché je vous le dis ça
n'est pas truquée je vous jure qu'il est
évidemment le premier ministre c'était
vraiment manuel valls ou quand même
équipe à poubelles malin tout le monde
connaît matches devant nous quoi qu il
fasse pas le malin parce que moi je peux
dessiner françois hollande vient au café
vient encadrer et à fait qu'elle au café
serait les collants de mon pote mesures
comme chez vous c'est parce qu'on a
pensé mais j'adore cette émission qui
peut être que c'est ça comment je vous
jure qu'on est d'avoir le premier
ministre au téléphone c'est quand même
super il sait pas qui vous êtes fait pas
demander à mes élans de sympathie pour
vous jean-luc non mais moi je suis
étonné parce que c'est la preuve que
tout le monde connaît matthieu delormeau
donner mais je pense que ça va se faire
ça va se faire c'est sûr je vois la
mairie coup si vous y allez pour le coup
moi je m'en fous même au café ou
chocolat je m'en fous je viens vous avez
été invité vous moi j'ai beaucoup de
boulot enfin vous pouvez décider que le
premier ministre quand même à côté du
ballon et où l'on appelle il voit dans
mon agenda il appelle mon mec il est
actif il a été ma roue je vous jure je
reviens je reviens pas que j'ai une
émotion
oh